ではよろしくお願いします
今日はいわゆる聖徳太子の生の話ですから
かなり歴史的な話 まああの
まあちょっとまあ冗談でね
まあいわゆるこの日本で古くからこの聖徳太子様をね
あの褒め称えるために使っている
まあ使用されている逸話で
10人ぐらいの人の話は同時に聞いて判断
決断することができたと
それが我々の解釈では
まあ耳が 6個あったっていうことになるんであって
別に皆様方が信じて覚えている物語ではそういうふうなことはありません
はい お願いします いや
お願いします はい 右のね
またこっちですね まあ一応お釈迦様のウェーサーカ祭りですから
まあ最初に で 耳が2個でしたということで
で 一応サブタイトルはね
あれこれと同時にいろんなことをやりたがる
我々も聖徳太子になりたがるという気持ちはないわけじゃないんです
なぜならば そのエピソードは
まあそのためにすごいぞと言われると
私たちもすごくなりたくはなります
そういうことですから
同時にたくさんのことができればそれがありがたいと思われるが
分析してみたことはありません
それからまあ 私の話で
一応どんな人でも まあいたま簡単に聖徳太子みたいにたくさん仕事をいっぺんにできれば
なんてありがたいことですかと思います
自分でも何かできればいいんじゃないかなとね
足で一つの仕事で 手に一つの仕事やらね
また口で別な仕事やらね
できればすごい簡単なことでね
まあ例えば学校で生徒たちに真剣真面目に教えながら
自分がまあ恋人に手紙を書くとか
同時にまあ同時にできれば時間は儲かりますけどね
まあ一応そういうふうなことはまあできればいいなと思いますが
まあそれできるかないかは知る前に
その能力って何なのかと分析しなくちゃいけないんですね
それでやっぱり客観的に分析してみます
これからは たくさんことをいっぺんに行う
とまずどうなるか 分析する前に結果で考えます
一つはもう何一つもうまくいかないんですね
我々 たくさんのことをいっぺんにやると
まあこれはわかっていますと思いますけどね
中途半端になるんですね
手抜きが起こるんですね
たくさん仕事を抱え込んだら
中途半端にいい加減でやるか
いろいろ手抜きをしてごまかすかっていうことに当然なりますね
それから忘れたりサボったりもしますね
あまりやりすぎていろんな仕事を忘れちゃうし
あるいは知ってはいるんだけど
他のことで忙しいんだから
その仕事をサボったりもします
それもまあよくある話で
またあります で 疲れるんですよ
ストレスが溜まるんですよ
たくさん仕事をしちゃうと疲れるし
ストレスが溜まるし それからまあ当然なことにお落ち着きがなくなる
それで精神的には混乱します
今まではまあ 6番目までいきましたけど
まあ一応いいことっていうのは一つもないんですよ
これは私はもういちいち君と長く説明しなくても
大体はまあわかることで
そこはわかるんだけど
その時皆様が何言うんですか？やっぱり自分に能力ないんだからなんです
能力あるんだったら そんなことにはならないんではないかと思うかもしれません
残念ながらそこで終わらないんですね
この話は 失敗が多い いろんなことに手を出しちゃうと
必ず失敗が多いんですね
それでやがて自信がなくなるんです
失敗が大きくなると まあ当たり前の結果で
人間というのは自信がなくなっちゃうんです
だからそういうのは社会現象で
世界現象で どんな人と喋ってみても
大体九十九パーセントの人々っていうのは自信がないんですね
声が通らないし いつでもなんかまああの謙虚で控えてるんじゃないんですよ
ただ自信がなくて控えてるんです
この控える方法 まああの人はすごい控えめでいい人やと
これ言いにくいんですよ
これ自信がないんじゃないかという
だから世の中大体みんなまあすごい丁寧で
謙虚で控えて控えているそうなことは見えますけど
よく見るとそうじゃなくて
結局は何か頼んだら それをやりあげることをやり遂げることという自信がない
そういうことなんですね
そこで九番目はまあすべて放棄してしまう
これ あれこれやってやってる人々っていうのも
結局はもう全部やめてしまって何もしないことにもなります
これもよく見える現象で
あまりにもあれもやります
これもやりますというふうにね
抱え込んでできなくなった場合は放棄しちゃうとかね
まあ何でもかんでも政治家なんか放棄してくれればそれほどありがたことないんですけど
まあそういう人以外はもう放棄したら困りますけど
やっぱり放棄しちゃうんですね
仕事は この放棄っていうことは
仕事だけじゃなくて あらゆる面に時々もうご飯食べることもやめちゃう場合もあるし
お風呂に入ったりすることまでもやめちゃう場合もあるし
部屋から外へ出ようともしない時もありますよ
だからまあ放棄といったっても
いろんな形があるんです
時々暗くなるんですね
狭くなるんですね それで十番目は安らぎを感じない
何でもやろうとしちゃうと
決して安らぎを感じない
ニコニコと穏やかで楽しく
そういう気楽で生きる生きるっていうことができなくなるんです
で これで十一番目 これコンピューター考えてないんですね
この丸の字はたくさん必要っていうことは
十一になってくると丸がなくなるんです
まあ作らないわけないんですけど
この機種が変わると この文字の一番最初の文字のちょっと問題があったんです
いろいろすごいデザイン的な文字を選んでやったんですけど
なかったので で 十一番目は不幸の原因
これが人間の不幸の原因
よく覚えておいてください
ありがたがるんじゃなくて
何でも同時にやってしまう
あれもこれもいっぱい仕事をしてしまうぞと思うことが我々の不幸の原因なんです
ですから まあそれでも覚えてほしいです
でまあ またありますよ
だから分析するとそういうことになるんです
我々は何も分析しないで
随分簡単勝手にたくさんことができるといいんじゃないかなと思っているだけで
で 欲があるから同時に同時進行が好き
なんで我々はこの同時進行好きですかね
これ欲なんですね いっぱい欲があって
あれもやってこれもやりたいと
あの これにお釈迦様がおっしゃったジャータカ物語があります
えーと まあお釈迦様の先祖物語として書いてますけど
まあそれはどうか分かりませんだけど
まあ一応仏教の世界が我々に教えて一つのこの教訓
モラルですよ ある国の王様がいて
まあこのまあ当然ジャータカ物語だからね
バーラナシ国のブラッハダッタ王様が統治していた時だからね
まあ結構苦労してきてる王様だと思いますけど
どんなジャータカ物語に出ていますからね
しかし このブラッハダッタ系だそうですね
この何年か前に亡くなったんで
最後のリンクが ブラッハダッタの王家の
ですから もうずっといたみたいで
その線戚の方々はね まあ王は今ではないんだからね
まあ潰されましたから
その中央インドにいた最後のバグダッドという名前のね
やっぱり前は王でしたけどね
ラージャでしたけども
亡くなりますとすごい年で
で 亡くなるまでみんなすごい信仰
信仰ではなくて尊敬されたんです
この末期の時だけみんなに顔を見せたりしていたりとか
まあ豊かなおじい様で
まあどうせかって王でしたからね
まあ豊かであることは問題ないです
まあそこの伝統かなと思いますけど
それでこの王様が まあどうも自分の国は小さすぎてもう気に入らないんですよ
それでいろいろ戦争したりして
戦略して隣隣の国を自分の国につないだんですね
つないでもうかなりもう大きいんです
今は でもまだもっとあの辺にあるんじゃないか
あの辺にあるんじゃないか
かなり遠いところの国も狙っちゃうんです
これは飛行機も何もないんだからね
歩いて行かなくちゃいけないでしょうに
で 戦争に行って行って勝っちゃったんだから
この人は言うことを聞かないということは
それでお釈迦様 菩薩 お釈迦様の先生ですから
菩薩って言うんですね
菩薩はその王様の一番目の顧問ですか
アドバイスする処理大臣みたいな感じでね
首相みたいな格にいたんです
で 彼が王様にね あの これやめた方がいいんだよ
そこら辺に行くことは
言ったら いえいえ 何言うんですかと
私にはここまで軍事力がありまして
これ潰せますよ その国は全然できますよ
だからあんたの言うことを聞かんと聞かなかったんですね
その代わりにいろいろみんなにアドバイスでちゃんとちゃんと軍軍隊を用意しなさいと
出かけます この出かけた時期が悪いんです
途中でお気になっちゃうんです
それは考えない この人もうかなりもう雨が全然降らないし
乾いてるし ではいいことで出かけましょう
でもこれは菩薩がもうその世界で知識人のプロの中プロだから
まあ計算は知っている
だから彼がここまで距離に行ったところで
もう全く何もできないように雨が降るんだよとわかっている
それで洪水になったり
雪崩にかかったりして
軍隊は全部全滅になるんだね
これ知ってるんです 言ってもこの人は聞かない
それで途中で行って ある大きな公園みたいなところで軍隊は止まって待っている
そこにたくさんの馬たちに食べさせるために
この豆とかね あの その時はだいたいこの美味しいものを食べさせるんですよ
なぜかというと この葉っぱ
草とか食べてね もう体力はないんだから
大量に食べなくちゃいけないんですね
もうこの豆やらいろんなものを食べさせちゃうと
いくら食べさせればもう栄養あるんだから仕事できるんですね
馬たちに ですから 特に馬たちに食べさせるために
結構美味しい豆がありまして
大きい豆なんですけど
それは茹でてさっと出しておいたんです
一人一人 それでどうせ森だから
周りはね そこからこの猿が落ちてきて
降りてきて あっちこっち見て
まあちょっと豆盗み食いというか
盗んで食べたいんですね
で 今と違って別に猿が豆ちょっとパクッと食べちゃってもね
どうったことはないし
どうせたくさんの馬たちに食べさせるためにあるものだから
馬でも全部舐めて食べるということではないしね
残したりするし だからあまり気にしなかったんですね
で 王様がどこかでちょっと座ってこれ見ているんです
猿がちょっと怯えて あっち見てこっち見て
まあ来るんですね 来て誰もいないんだから
パッと手いっぱいもう取れるぐらいたくさん取ったんです
豆 取っても誰も攻撃してくれない
だったらもう一つどうではないかと言って
次の手も左と右両方あります
その時にいっぱい取っちゃったんです
両手いっぱいでね 豆が見た
見たところで別に誰も気にしない
猿はこの豆盗むことには
これはいいことやと思って
で 口にいっぱい入れちゃって
口いっぱい食べられない
これってすごくたくさん詰め込んで
いっぱい一つの手で またたくさん豆があって
まだ取れるほど取れるぐらいのいっぱい取っちゃったんです
で 取って どこかにまあもうちょっと足で登って座って
もう食べようとして食べられますかね
口いっぱい 両手いっぱいで
食べようと思ったら プスンとこの手から豆が一粒二粒ぐらい落ちたんです
落ちた直感で この猿はあっしまったという感じで驚いちゃって
口を開けちゃったら 口の豆も全部落ちたんです
手を動かしちゃったんだから
手の豆も全部落ちちゃったんです
それで何もなくなっちゃうんです
王様がこれを見てゲラゲラ笑って
あんな あんなにバカな猿がね
もうこれは手一杯とか口一杯ぐらい持っていけばもう食べられるのに
あいつは全然何も食べられなくなっちゃった
本当に猿っていうのはバカだなとか言って
その話し合いになるのは
このアドバイスするこの
出家の大臣閣やってる人だから
顧問の顧問やってる大臣だから
他の人には命令するだけだから
その菩薩にいい話をしてあげるんです
私 すごいことを見たんだよ
今日はね 猿ほど本当にアホな動物はないんだと
こういうことやと説明するんですね
ほな 菩薩はじーっとその話を聞いていて
ああそう まあ私が王様
別に対した変わりがないと思いますけど
それを猿を笑うところじゃないでしょうと
大した変わりがないんだと
あなたやってること 何言うんですかと
だって これこれこれぐらい国を戦略して統治して
それで手一杯なのに これでじき外れた
これであなたは遠い遠方の国にも届いていてね
全部なくなりますよ 私は知ったことじゃないんだと
だから猿を笑うなよ 笑っては決していけません
王様はというと 言ったんです
それで気づいたんですね
あまり欲がありすぎると
持っているものがなくなります
それでまあ帰ったんですけど
帰るのも大変で また大雨に引っかかっちゃったんですけど
とにかく街に戻ることだから無事に戻ったんです
それでやっぱりこの大臣が言ったことは聞いた方がよかったとわかったんですね
そのジャータカ物語で言っているのは
この欲がありすぎると
それあの猿みたいという同じ
左手で一つと 右手で一つと
口でもう一つとやりたくはなるんです
それでいっぱい食べられるのではないかと
いっぱい得をするのではないかと思うんだけど
これで全部失いますよという話になるんですね
だから人間っていう すごく欲があるんだから
お金がかっこいいと思いますよ
同時に仕事を 2つできれば収入も 2倍でしょうに
そういう計算するんです
うん だから仕事をすれば収入がある
2つ仕事をすれば 2つ収入があるっていうのは
計算そこまではいいんだけど
仕事には時間がかかるという
あの なんとかファクターは忘れちゃうでしょう
計算するんだったら全てのファクターをまとめないと
これ一つの大事なファクターをね
これは時間で割らなくちゃいけないんですよ
だから ある時間単位でどれぐらい収入を得られるかっていうことは正しい結果なんです
例えば この仕事をすれば 1時間で 1万円もらうと
この仕事をすれば 1時間で 2,000円もらうというと
じゃあ 2つもやれば 1万2,000円でしょう
違うんですよ それで当然 1時間で仕事をすれば1万円
これで 2,000円で 1万2,000円なんですね
しかし  1時間  1時間とファクターで割らなくちゃいけないんですよ
割ってみたら答えは 6,000円です
1万2,000円じゃないんです
だから同時に仕事をしようとする人は
その収入は 6,000円ですよ
それで我々はだから一つ選びなさいよと
例えば 最初の仕事を選んだならば
1時間で 1万円は儲かっているのに
それはどうしてもやらない
やれないんだったら  2番目の仕事を選んで 2,000円もらっちゃえばいいでしょうに
どうしてもやらない仕事を選んで
これも選んでやっちゃうと 6,000
円もらえない 当たり 5,000円もらわないでしょうに
仕事できんだから それで 1,000円になってます
だからどっちにしたっても
一つ選ぶしか道がないんですよ
上手な人が両方選んじゃうと
収入が 6,000円 本人が計算した通りに 1万2,000円じゃないんです
下手な人が選んじゃうと収入が 1,000円なんです
そのことなんで だから欲でみんな行動するんだから
この計算は黒板に書く必要ないでしょう
とにかく時間というファクターで割らなくちゃいけないんですよ
これはすごく大事なことなんです
我々は欲があるんだから
その頭が狂ってしまって
計算がわからなくなっちゃって
同時にやりたくなる で
それでやろうとしたら何になるかというと
かわいそうなことにどんどん欲が増えるんですよ
だから欲のせいで同時進行を欲しがっちゃうでしょうに
それやってやろうと思っちゃうと
どんどん欲が増えるんです
6,000円儲かった人が決してわからないんで
損しているんだと  4,000円も全然気がつかないんです
じゃあ 6,000円儲かったんだから
これどうにかして 8,000円にしなくちゃいけないということになるんです 8,000
円にならないんですよ
だから欲が増えるっていうことは
とてもとてもじゃなくて
どんどん問題が大きくなること
それで欲が増えるとどうなるかというと
それで心が汚れて  14 番目
心は汚れてしまう 欲が増えるんだから当たり前です
それで 15 番目になってくると能力が消えることになる
結局は能力が増えてほしいところは
その人は逆効果で能力がどんどん減ってしまうんですね
それで終わりでしょうかと思ったら
まだ終わらないんですよ
この同時進行の欠点は
短所は 成功しないと失敗すると怒りが現れる
欲だけじゃない 次にもう失敗するでしょうに
自分の計画通りに成功していないでしょうに
すごく怒るんです 機嫌が悪くなるんです
失敗する それでその人は他人を攻撃したくなる
だから我々はこの世の中で生きていられないでしょうに
みんな攻撃しよう 攻撃しようと
会社に行ったら上司かもう自分の失敗
なんらかの部下に当ててブッダに当たるでしょうに
部下もまた次にくる人々に当たるでしょうにも
どうにもならんことなんですね
関係ない人々を攻撃する
だから我々生きてる世界というのは
そういう世界になっているんですね
静かに生活しようと思ったってもできないんですよ
誰が知らんやつが出てきて攻撃するんですよ
こちらに関係ないのに
なんかはっきり言えば
なんか人間っていうのはみんな通り魔みたいなもんなんですよ
誰が誰を攻撃するかわからない
自分の気分が悪くなったら誰かに当たる
そういうことになるんですよ
それで終われなくて 自己嫌悪に陥る
次に もう何のことなく自己嫌悪に陥る
それでまた能力が減ることになる
同じこと 自己混迷に陥るとさらに能力が減る
だから今まで何回私は能力が減るっていうことを書きますよ
で 書いてます なぜかというと
どんどん能力が減っていっていくいくような過程になるんです
それが 19 で またあります
それだけじゃない 人格もガタガタになるんですよ
真剣さが失われる 人間というのは真剣でしっかりしないとあかんでしょうに
でもほとんどの人間には真剣さがないんですね
それだけじゃない バカになっちゃうんです
物事を理解する余裕がないんですね
あんまり無駄がすぎる
それでさらに頭が悪くなるでしょう
そういうわけで無知の創福
結果としてありがたく無知を育てるんです
だから生きていればいるほど頭が悪くなるという過程になるんです
そういうのは客観的な事実ですよ
世の中を調べてみてください
自分のことでもいいんです
どんどんなんか調べてみると
バカになっていくんじゃないんですか
23 番目 これは説明必要と思いますけど
経験にならない これどういう意味ですか？これは一般的な意味で
人間っていうのは何でも経験でしょ
経験していけばいくほど能力が向上するでしょうに
物事を知るでしょうに
1 人前になるでしょうに
だから人間というのは何でもいいんだから経験するべきなんです
だから経験というのは悪いことじゃない
生きるってことは経験の連続でしょうに
しかし こんなような生き方は経験にならないんですよ
いわゆる何か自分には付け加えてくれないんです
自分の人格に 性格に それが私は簡単で経験にならないと書いたんです
ということは 我々はどんどん経験を積み重ねて生きていかなくちゃいけないんです
新しいことを新しいことを経験していくと
どんどん頭が良くなって
理解能力が広くなって
落ち着く人間になります
人格が向上する だから経験が大事なんです
付け加えることが この人々は必死に焦って生きてるんだけど
何一つも経験が積み重なったことにならない
付け加えたことにならない
だから この 23 というのはかなり大変な大事なポイントなんです
それで 24 番 他人をいじきになるということだ
他人のいじきになる だから見事に現代我々は誰かさんの誰かさんのいじきでしょ
コマーシャルの通りに
いろいろ宣伝に言われる通りに
政治家やらいろんな有名な人々に言われる通りに
まあ猿みたいに動いているだけです
誰も幸福になりません
この人に物事を喋る人は
自分の利益のために喋っているんです
はい 日本の国民のためにと大きい声で喋るんだったら
その人はもう自分の利益のために喋っているんであって
それに乗せた人々はみんな餌食になるだけ
だから結局人間っていうのは
いつでも社会の人々の
悪い人々の餌食になって生きてるんですよ
もう逃げられないんですね
自由っていうのは感じないんですよ
それがこの結果なんで
何も経験もないんだから
何でもやりたがるんだから
だから人に言うことを聞くしかなくなりますね
25は能力が増えて成功する
する道だと思ったら 結果は逆になる
逆 まあ短く書けば逆効果の結果になるということなんですけどね
我々はたくさんことをやると
能力が増えるんだそう
成功するんだそう たくさん儲かるんだそうと思ってはいたんですが
結局私は前も計算して見せたんだから
結果としては逆 損ばっかりする
能力が減る  26は自分のことを自分で判断することができず
他人に頼る 他に頼る よくあるんですよ
社会で いつでも人にどうすればいい
どうすればいいんだ あなたのことだから
自分に私はどうやって知ってるんでしょうか？と聞きたいんですけど
この赤ちゃんが夜に夜泣きするんだけど
どうすればいいんだ？知るわけないでしょ
自分の家の赤ちゃんでしょうに
他人に聞くんですよ だから自分の家で
自分の寝る布団の中で一緒に寝ている赤ちゃんでしょう
これはどこかの誰かさんが知ってるわけないでしょうに
でもいつでも我々は他人にどうすればいいか
どうすればいいんだと聞くのは
そういう能力がないんだから
それからたくさん仕事があると
どうしても聞かなくちゃあかんことになるんですよ
自分が抱えた仕事だから
それは自分でやらなくちゃいけないんです
人に聞くもんじゃないんです
人に聞いても真剣に教えてくれるわけでもないんです
かえって協力したくなくなっちゃいますよ
私はこれとこれとこれぐらい仕事を取っているんだから
これやれないんだよと
いっぺんに だからあんたこれどうすればいいか早く教えてくれって言ったら
あなたわがままでそんなことやったなら勝手にしろよという気持ちになるんですよ
こちらに文句を言うなよと
だから我々はよく他人に相談するんですけど
あまり親切に相談には乗ってくれないんですよ
で だから結局は他人に頼ることになって
自立心はなくなりますね
27は進行して終えるはずの人生は退化で終わる
よく覚えておいてください
まあそこら辺で終わりますけど
この素晴らしい徳が同時進行の
この進行して終えるはずの人生でしょ
日々成功して大きな人間になっていくはずなんですけど
結局死ぬ時は誰でも退化して死ぬんです
元にあった前にあった栄光もないし
輝きもないし 人気もないし
能力もないし 何もない
もう暗闇で退化して死ぬことになるんです
それでたくさんのことをいっぺんに行うと
これは仏教の一般的な言い方で言うならば
それは地獄への道なんです
だから聖徳太子にはならん方がいいんです
これが地獄への道なんです
今まで何番まで行ったか忘れちゃった
何番でしたっけ？ 27
え  27 で それは全部地獄への道なんです
不幸の道なんです それでも同時にたくさんのことができれば
それに越した 越したことですね
越したことはありません
ちょっと打ち間違いです
そう思うでしょう 今まで 27項目を読んでみたっても
やっぱり一緒にできればそれに越したことはないと思っちゃいますね
なぜそうなる？なってしまいますかね
なぜそう思ってしまうのでしょうかね
できると思っているんでしょうか
ゆっくり読みます これは私の勘違いなんです
それがすごい勘違いなんですよ
同時にできる 同時にやりたいと思うことは
見事な勘違いなんです
一つしか知らない世間知らずより
様々なことを知ってる方が良い
マルチタレント能力と同時にあれこれをやることは同じではありません
それで緑で書いているのは
まあこれは一般の一般的な考え方で
人しか知らない世間知らずになるよりは
様々なことを知っている方がいいんじゃないかとみんな思っているんですよ
それは私たちの一般的な考え方
しかし 仏教の答えはマルチタレント能力と同時にあれこれやることは同じではありませんと
これちょっとわかりにくいんですよ
上 緑色で考えているのはこのマルチタレントなんですよ
このマルチタレントになることと
何でもいっぺんにやることっていうのは同じじゃないんです
すぐにわかると思います
そこでガイド ガイドっていうのはマルチ
マルチタレントはいいんですが
どうやればマルチタレントになるかということなんですね
目指しても良いこと かっこいいことは何ですかね
その色が違うんですね
自分が計算する色と出ている色っていうのは
どちらも緑で計算したんですけど
あれ これだとスクリーンでリハーサルやってみないとわからないみたい
緑で計算してたんですけど
まあそれはどうでもいいんです
緑でもこの色でも で 多重複数多数マルチ能力があることです
それが目指すべきですよ
それであまりにも強調するために
私は多重複数多数ありとあらゆる言葉を使ったんです
別にどうでもいいんですけどね
いわく たくさん能力があった方がいいってことなんです
いわゆるこのマルチ能力
で 日本語でよく使ってますね
マルチマルチマルチタレントタレントという言葉がね
まあそれは日本語で使っているよりは
英語で考えるとマルチタレントっていうのは素晴らしいことなんですよ
タレントっていうのは能力だから
あの そのテレビに出てバカなことをやっているっていう意味じゃないんです
それは日本語だけ 日本だけかな
あの言葉は この芸能人に使っているのはタレントさんと
わからないんですが かなり検討できてないんだから
これ大量の過ぎはそれで必ず避けるべきかっこ悪いことって何ですか？ゆっくり聞きます
それはむやみに何でも同時にやりたがることです
これはすごいかっこ悪いんですよ
だから このあれこれ同時にやりたがることはものすごいかっこ悪いんです
かっこいいことは前に書いたんです
マルチタレントになることはすごいかっこいいんです
だからこれまた色が違う
だからかっこ悪く見えますよ
本当は元のデザインは結構いいんですけど
たくさんの能力があることをと
これ回ってくれます 大丈夫です
何でも抱え込んで一緒に同時にいっぺんにやろうとする
落ち着きのない無知な生き方が
相反するものなので 一緒に調理しないことは賢いことです
よく覚えておいてください
これが相反するものなんです
それで理解してほしいのは
まあ例えば あの 何て言いますか
農業もできると 米の作り方もしっかり知ってますと
それだけじゃなくて 自分にはもう作家としていろんな作品も書けるんだよと
立派な農業をできるエグリカルチャーリストで
でもそれに自分で好き勝手に田んぼを作っているんですけど
それで余裕な時間ですごい立派な作品
本を書いたりする 作家ですよ
すごいかっこいいでしょ？タレント 2つあるんだから
その上 その人はかなりこの音楽も書ける人よ
いろいろ音楽も書いてるんだ
言えばもっとかっこいいでしょ
本を書いて疲れたところで
いろいろ音楽を作詞作曲してみると
それで疲れる時はまた本を書き始める
それで体がなんかだるくなったら田んぼに行って仕事をするとかね
マルチタレント 決して悪くないんですよ
それかっこいいんです
それだったらタレントという能力っていうのはいくらあってもいいんです
しかし それいっぺんにできますかね
あの田んぼでトラックで土をこしながらもう小説書いてると
できるわけないでしょう
そうすると大変危険なことになりますからね
だから同時にやってはいけない
これ相反するものなんです
トラクターを運転しながらギターで何か呼吸を考えていると
そういうながら これ事故を起こしてるでしょうに
だから同時にやることと能力がたくさんあるということは相反するものです
で 一緒にしない方がいいということなんです
一応ここら辺で半分は終わりました
今日は早く終わります
疲れていましたので みんなこのレーサー祭りの準備です
これは肉ですから どうします？ちょっと休憩取りますか
じゃあ 10 分間休憩させていただいたらと思います
では続けていきます これから仏教の話はまあちょっと難しいかもしれませんだけど
心は同時に複数の認識は行わないのです
心のことを知っているのはお釈迦様だけだから
お釈迦様は心のことを調べたら
これは同時にたくさん仕事をしないんですよ
心は なのにやろうとするとね
だから心っていうのはこのシリアルシステムですよ
このパラレル的に行動はしません
だから同時にたくさんできないで
これは本来できない とんでもないことを言います
それでこのよく覚えてください
仏教の心の説明では いわゆる心理学では心理学なんですけど
仏教の心理学というのは
心っていうのはこの 1本でシリアルで機能しているのです
ある一定の時間で一つの仕事しかできないのです
これで時間で言えば 1時間
3時間で計算するんだから
これややこしくなっているんであって
ナノ秒ぐらいで考えた方がいいんですよ
ナノ秒で言ったってわからない
私もわからないですけどね
秒の 1000分の 1ぐらいにでもして考えてください
それぐらいもっと早いんですけど
心はそうやって瞬間の時間で
ちょっと瞬間のひと仕事しかしないんです
そこに仏教から次のところ
で パラレルパラレルにパラレル行動をさせようとする場合は
えーと この心という機械は異常現象を起こす
だからパラレル行動できないんだから
心に 我々は欲張って無知で愚かなもので
パラレル行動させようとすると
心が必ず異常現象を起こしちゃうんですね
それで故障する だから人類っていうのはみんな精神的にはおかしいんです
健康じゃないんで 精神的には
これがこの同時に 2つやらせているんだからなんです
で 故障する 予測できない行動をする
人間やっていることでも予測できないでしょ
明日どうするかもうわからない
突然襲われる可能性もあるし
もうよくよくすごい立派にまともでいた人が
突然もう悪い行動をしたり
犯罪を起こしたりもするし
だから自分のことはもう予測できない
もうそれがこのパラレルで
パラレルって何ですか？日本語で
並列  並列  並列 並列動作
並列的に物事をやろうとするんだから
この精神的な病気の問題が起こるんですよ
それだけじゃなくて 機能低下する
どんどん心が本来持っている能力が見事に低下する
これ付け加えて言いますけど
この仏教では人相の話があるんですよ
お釈迦様はどこどこに行きたければ
遠いところに時々この何ヶ月間かけていらっしゃった時もあります
ゆっくりと日々楽しみながら
そこら辺の人々とよく話して
またそこで夜泊まって
朝まで説法して また朝出かけて次に出かける
また次の町 次の村 次の村という順番で
でも いつでもそれをなさったわけでないんです
瞬間に別なところに行ったりもします
そこでどうやって瞬間に何百キロ
万キロも行けるんですかね
心にはその能力があるんですよ
いわゆる現代風に言えば瞬間移動
機械は要りません この体の分子をね
素粒子化して また別なところで構成するという
いわゆる科学的なそんなことをこの SF 映画なんかで考えてるでしょ
あんなのはありえないんです
素粒子は素粒子だから
そこら辺のどんな素粒子でいいんですよ
鉄は鉄だから 私が今持っている同じ鉄でなければいかんということないでしょうに
そこら辺どんな鉄分でもいいんです
だからご飯食べるたびに新しい鉄分やら物質が入りますから
だからこの物理学で考えている瞬間移動っていうのは
仏教はありえない 成り立たない
わかる もう関係ないから
はい で どうにか私は見たこともやったこともないんだからわかりませんだけど
お釈迦様は瞬時に別のところに現れる
だから 例えばこちらで説法なさっていて
今誰かさんには今の瞬間で説法しなくちゃいけないんだと
その人は今説法を聞いたら悟るぞとわかったら
そのまますぐそちらに消える
ただ消えるだけ 消えてまたまたそちらにいるんです
そこで そちらでその人の話あって
説法して終わったらまた元に戻るんです
またもう一つなさったんです
こちらにいながら こちらの人々にする説法は理解できる
他の何か所にいる人々にも同時に放送する
それが現代で言えばテレビみたいな感じで
それぞれのところで放送する
だからその時はちゃんとお釈迦様は見えるんです
3次元で だから聞いてる人々はさっぱり区別わからないんだと
どちらに本物がいるんでしょうかと
みんな いえ 私のところにお釈迦様は実際のお釈迦様がいるんだぞと
だからそういうのは で
現代人がね 嘘やと片付けたいんですけど
もう我々は聞きません
そんな人の話なんかはろくなことをできない
自分の子供を育てることもできない人のことを聞くと思いますか？頭がいいどころか
だからまあ こういう今の時代の人々いうことを全然聞きません
もっと違う違う世界があるんです
信じられない世界があるんです
だからお釈迦様がその
ものすごく心を育てたんですよ
育てたんだから 心の本来の能力は戻っただけ
だから仏教の第一芸で言ってるでしょうに
心は支配者で 心は先導者で
心はもうよしというかリーダーで
物事は心が創造してるんだよ
でも私たち知ってる心は奴隷で
物質の何の権力も能力も持ってないでしょ
お腹が空いたら落ち込むんだから
それだけの心でしょ 持ってるのは
何のリーダーシップも取ってないんですよ
だから最悪の状態でいるんですよ
だから逆効果になっているんです
これは人間が犬に飼われているような感じなんですよ
犬が人間に命令して あれこれやりなさいとかね
犬が人間を散歩に連れているとかね
そんなのって考えてあり得るんでしょうかと
でも実際 心と体の関係でそうなっているんです
しっぽが犬を振っているんです
犬がしっぽを振っているんじゃなくて
だから結構無理をしてるんですよ
ちょっと想像してください
しっぽが止まった 固定したままで体が振ってるんだから
そんなようなことをやっています
だからこのこのパラレル並列で物事をしようとすると
結局はどんどん機能が低下して
もう鈍足のレベルで今あるんです
人間の心の力は それをなんとか直さなくちゃいけないというのが仏教の話なんです
いろんな能力ありますよ
信じられない と 信じられない一つも
どうせ当てればいい 物質なんかはもう全くのもう飼っているみたいな感じで
もう好き勝手に動かせるんです
そこでこの同時並列で仕事をすると
期待する結果は生み出せないんですね
だからお釈迦様の苦のドッカの苦しみの説明で一つありますね
人間はもう望むことは得られない苦しみがあるんだと
これみんなにあるんです
我々はいろんなことを望んではいるんだけど
一つも得られない 望むと
望むのは望むほど その目的が遠ざかっていくんですね
これ何なのかと 自分が気に入っている人が追っかけていればいるほど
それは逃げるでしょう
大体普通の世界ではね
自分が気に入っているのに
その人はすごく嫌いと思っちゃう
自分が嫌いと思ってるんですけど
その人は自分のことを好きでいてね
もう襲ってくる どうにもならん世界なんです
ですから この望む結果はいつでも遠ざかっているのを
この我々は同時並列行動のことの結果なんですね
そこでまた仏教からのアドバイスなんですけど
心の知り合い 機能の法則に従って行動するならば大変楽です
この苦しみもストレスも
あの 27項目も消えるんですよ
ものすごい楽になる マニュアル通りに動かせちゃうと
この機械を 現代の電気機器と同じくコード 2本で配線が済みます
シリアルだからコード 2本で必要なのは
だから この瞑想する人々はよくわかるんですよ
このすごい複雑ですよ
瞑想は進んでいない場合はやりきれない
どんどん進んでいくと
ただすべて信号 2つで済みます
そこで心も情報のウとムだけの信号で認識機能をしているのです
心にも全くこの電気機械機械と同じく
あるなしだけで十分なんです
だから この日本の線であるなしだけのデータで完璧に生きられるのです
実際も我々はそういうふうにやっているんですよ
しかし 同時にたくさん仕事をしようとすると
今のコンピューターみたいにもうパンク起こしちゃうわ
もう凍ってしまうわ もうもうプログラム突然止まるわ
もう作った文章は消えてしまうわ
昨日もものすごくもうもう苛立ちすぎて
もういや ありゃしないぐらいなんですね
たったちょっとした 3行の文章を書いて
これ印刷しようとすると
やってくれない 一つの文字
作るサクッという文字なんですよ
これ印刷しないんです
それで何回何回もチャレンジできない
そこで行動の誤りがあるんだぞとかね
ポストスクリプトエラーが出ましたと
こちらに言うなよと こちらは何もやってないんだから
ただ何時間もかかっただけだったら
我々素朴的に手で書いたならば
あれ 10 分  15 分で全てあれば
例えば A3 の 3枚だからね A3
の 3枚でちょっとお知らせ書いたかったんですよ
あればペンで書けば 10 分で済みますね
だからもうあれでもパラレル進行でやろうと思って
結構時間もなくなっちゃって疲れてしまって
今も怒ってるんですわね
で それでまた仏教からのアドバイスなんですけど
で これからちょっとかなり省略しましたけど
ちょっと難しいんですけど
仏教というのは機能ごとに移行させることなんです
で これが難しいんです
話は だからもうできるだけ省略します
機能ごとにっていうのは
我々も何か仕事をこなすためにはいくつかの機能が必要でしょ
車を運転するってだったら
目の視力も必要でしょうし
聴覚も必要でしょうし
手の足の動きも必要でしょうし
いろんな機能必要ですよ
ではそれ同時 できるか同時にはできません
だから この機能ごとに育成すればいいんです
このバカなことをやめて
例えば歌いたいと でも声がないんですよ
音楽なんか習ったこともない
あの なん なん あれ 何て言いますか
あの あの  音符ですか  え？楽譜で
もうあの あれも読めない
あの蛙のなんとかみたいな形でやるやつはね
音符ね 音符 音符も読めない人がね
それ突然歌ってやろうと思っても
もう平仮名には歌えないでしょうに
で 本当に一人前でプロで歌いたければ
機能別に育成すればいいんです
自分で決めて じゃあまず楽譜を習うか
でも声が出ない人にとっては楽譜で理解してできないでしょうに
ドレミファソラに合わせて歌うことは
音程を合わせたりとかね
だからまず声さえも出ないんだから
まあ考えてみれば まず声を出す
練習する 歌でなくてもいいんです
馬鹿野郎とかなんとか言ったってもいいんです
それはちゃんともうお腹からもう歌もう
ものすごい声で言って
言って この筋肉のトレーニングをする
もうそうすると いとも簡単に軽々ともう千人にでも響き渡る声が自然に出るようになる
それからその声でドレミファソの音程
音程を訓練する そういう風に
そうすると楽譜を読める
で 声もある 次にその人は次のトレーニングを受けて
だから歌っていうのは演奏だから
あのパフォーマンスだ
パフォーマンスだから
それはちゃんとやらなくちゃいけない
それからこの歌の内容の感情やら表すものやら
それはちゃんと表現して
喋ることを次に習って
それから全部合わせる
次に それで何の苦労もなく歌えるんですね
その時は その人は音をどうやって出せばいいかとか考えちゃうとできなくなっちゃうんです
あれは自動的についてやるんです
今はもうどんな音程でしょうかとかもう悩まなくても
それは自動的に出ている
その人はもう表現するときだから
この感情をいかに表す
表せるかと それだけに集中すればいいんです
時々いるでしょ テレビで歌いながら涙もろい
だからその歌のその一部で
その感情を表さなくちゃいけないんですよ
その人は音程何なのかとかね
発声を全然もう気にしません
だから見事に歌う だからやっぱり能力っていうのは
この機能別に育てた方が仏教は進むんですよ
世の中でもプロらしいプロは機能別に能力を育てるんですよ
何でも野球でもそうなんですよ
いきなり試合って誰がやらせるんですかね
全部機能別に習うんですよ
バッティング練習やら球を守る練習やらキャッチボールやら
あれやこれやと それだけで終わらないんです
瞬時に反応できるような
その訓練 また別にやる
別なところで バットも球も何もないところで
それで視力も必要でしょうに
だって球プロだったら見えませんだからね
あの球 見えないものでも瞬時に見て判断しなくちゃいけないんです
素人には見えませんよ
プロが投げる球 それでその訓練もする
それから落ち着きがなくなっちゃどうにもならんだから
だから常に落ち着いていることも訓練する
いろんなことを訓練して
一人前のプロになります
私が一流と思っている人は
皆様そう思ってないんだけど
しょうがないんですけど
野球の世界だからね で
皆様が思っているようなそれだったら
この何でしたか？あの人は松井さんみたいになる
私から言えばイチローみたいな完璧な人間になる
その世界に ですから やっぱり同時に何でもやろうとするというのは無茶な話ではなくて
やっぱり機能別に育てた方がいいんです
そうですね で 無窮の教育世界はね
今ないんですけど いくらかミャンマーでは残っているみたいですけどね
この機能別に育てるというやり方でやるんです
例えば仏教を勉強するときでも
我々のは最初にやらせるのはもう一旦は暗記させる
まあ子供でしょうし こんなややこしいことわかるわけないし
とにかく暗記しなさいと
あれやこれやとか もう何でも暗記させる
何暗記してるとかさっぱりわからない
その人々はパーリ語がわからない
パーリ語の文法法 デクレーションシステムという
この何といいますか 格変化を
あらゆる名詞を格変化させる方法やら
それを全部リストで暗記する
動詞の変化方法 全然意味がわからない
ただ暗記する がっちりでがっちゃんで
がっちでがっちでがっちゃいがっちゃん
がっちってがっちゃんってがっちせがっちでがっちゃう
ま へがっちゃう あ へとわかんないけど
ずっと暗記するんです
だからまあ一応 例えば私と言えば
パーリ語で言ったらアスミっていうアハンという言葉でしょ
それ私が私たちがとかね
私を私たちよとかいろいろ変化するんですよ
我々はアハン マヤンマメマン
マヤンマカーンマメ マヤメメミヤンメヒ
マヤミヤンミハメ マヤ
メ マイハンマンママン
アンマカーンアムロとか
そういうずっとリストが暗記させてるんです
最初はいやで何やってるんですか？と
でも何もわからないから
音だけのことだから暗記できる
そこで 1年前 死ぬまで必要なものは
もうすらすらすら暗記してるんです
子供も それ終わったら
ではこの 意味を理解しようと
次にこの単語のいや 単語の辞書を暗記させるんですよ
辞書と言ったっても まだ同義語辞書なんです
それもあまり本を出してないんです
みんな暗記でやってますから
例えばブッダといえば
100 120種類の言葉があって
もうざーっと それはもうリストで暗記する
だからブッダバカバ阿羅漢サンマサンブドナガスよ
タカハと ものすごいたくさんあります
プリサーズ後なるっても
それは全部もう同義語で暗記する
そこでこのオンリストっていうものはパーリ語にあります
あれ この芸なんかはあるスタイルで作らなくてはい
それは次に芸を選んで
何々オンリストはこれであると暗記するんです
それはそのオンリストで暗記するんです
で この節を入れて それでもうぴったり
それをまだ知らないんですよ
それで全部 もう結構大人にもうなって
まあ三期ばっかしあって
もう 23歳  4  4歳かもしれません
それで先生はいきなり何かテキストを出して
もう言葉で意味はわかってる
君 これあの翻訳しなさいと
翻訳って言ったら口でやらせるんです
文章ではないんです まず文章をあげて
例えばパーリ語だったら A1 メスタンってありますね
A1 メスタン A1 というのはこれこれで
メスタンというのはこれこれ
で そうやって言ってる
いう場合はなぜそうなるんでしょうか？と文法的な分析と
どのような どういう風に定義するべか
それ全部言いなさい いっぺんに言わなくちゃいけない
だからもう大学で博士課程で博士課程で研究する人々よりもはるかにレベル高く
この若者いきなりやらせるんです
できます ほんで一つテキスト終わったら
まあいいやと お前もう帰ると
それでその人に見切り出るものはないんです
それでもまだ終わらないんですよ
かなり怖いんです 昔の学問の王って
次に解釈学っていうものを教えるんです
これは皆様 現代人みたいに何か見て自分勝手でかい
それはできません 我々にはそれなりの長い学問があるんです
解釈するときに まあ例えば
まあブッダっていうのはまあ苦しいことですよ
苦しいって意味だよと
そう言うと ものすごく怒鳴られます
あんた なんでそんなこと言うんですか？根拠を言いなさい
それでドッカといえば
このことから見るとこの意味です
この教えから見るとこの意味です
これから見るとこの意味ですって
あらゆる意味をさーっと並べて言わなくちゃいけない
これはパーリ語の注釈書では一応そのスタイルで書いてあるんですけど
注釈学がありますから
A 1 というのは 一般的な日本語訳は格のごとくこのようにということなんです
しかし 注釈書で最初に A 1 を定義する場合は
2 3 ページ続けてです
A 1 という言葉は このように
このように このように使いますよと言って意味合いをするんです
で それで解釈学もまた叩き込んであげる
それからその人は仏教は誤解するという心配は全くないし
どんな人にも自信を持って教えることができるのです
それたった勉強という
たった一つですよ 普通の学校で勉強するっていうこと
それなのに それたった一つの科目
パーリ語と仏教だ ってもきめ細かく分析して
能力別に育てるんです
だから 昔風にお寺から出された人っていうのは
もう大変な人間なんです
だから 自分の国が西方的になっちゃって
教育システム全て西方的になって
西洋的な大学出てきて
みんな我々は西洋的に
現代的にやるんだぞと始めたんですけど
何も型書きない 学位は一つも持ってない
ただのお坊さんたちのところでは
口は開けることさえできない
当時はイギリス植民地の時代である
あの提督ですか？ガガーンの提督
提督がなんかこの仏教ですね
総督 総督がね あの仏教やらね
なんとか勉強したかったんです
それでここに勉強したいったら
まあ周りはね しかしそれはいいことですけど
お坊さんを呼ぶことだけはできませんよ
これ植民地なんですよ
それはできる あなたが寺に行くしかないんだよ
たとえ総督でもそう簡単に動かせません
ということで 彼がもう定期的にキャルミットというバラモンの近いところに
私たちの学校側の大本の学校ですけど
そちらに定期的に来て授業を受けたんです
だから植民地で総督ではどれくらい格があると言ったって
やっぱりその人が寺に来なくちゃいけないんです
来てくれたらできませんって言うんだったら
学生たちがいるんだから忙しい
それは忙しいんですから
もう夜までもういつでもどこで学校やってるかわかりませんけど
やっぱり弟子たちが一周回りでいろいろその時々いろいろ仕事してるだけなんですけど
その場でその場でずっとしてるんですよ
例えば庭が葉っぱ落ちてきてなかったら
それは掃除しながら先生がそちらに掃除するならば
他の弟子たちが行って
あの 手伝いをする その間でも何かずっと教えてるんです
私もすっごいいろんなことをそうやってこの先生に
あの なんて言いますか
それは もう手伝いに行って
何か先生が仕事をしていると
私はこの道具を渡してあげるぐらいのね
あの脚立に乗ったら脚立をつかまってあげるぐらいの
まあ協力はするんですけど
いつでも何か教えてくれるんです
いつでもいつでも その場でその場で
だからすごいやり方なんです
ですから このそういう伝統的な勉強ができたならば
もう終わる場合はもう見事に一流の完璧な人物に育て上げるという
これができるんですよ
人間にみんなに同じ脳細胞あるんだから
生まれる時はいろいろ性格の差があるかもしれませんだけど
それで能力別に育てると完璧な人間になるんです
これをやりましょうと我々は仏教側から言うんですよ
この何も心ってあるっていうことさえも知らない
西洋人の話に何で乗るんですかと
魂があると思ってるでしょ
いまだに 特別に神様がその人々だけを守っていると思ってるでしょ
そこまで原始人の話に何で乗るんですかと
物事を宇宙スケールで考えている世界に
話はなんて馬鹿にするんですかと
だから人間には別に区別は
生まれる時があるかもしれませんだけど
そんなのはどうったことない
もう人の心は能力別に育てると育てられます
だから私はそういう思考だから
私は音楽は全くもう何も知らない
まあ仏教だから禁止でしょうし
もう楽器触ることもできないし
で お寺でそんなこと触って見つけたらね
もう もう通用するかもしれませんだからね
お寺ってのはそんな優しくないんですよ
何やるのかわからない
で だからできない でも私は今何？歌えないんだからといって
私は歌えと思ってないんです
やればできる ただ訓練していないだけだ
すごく目腹見張ると言うんですかね
胸張るんです 誰かがすごい見事にピアノを弾いていると
なんてことは感動する
まあ能力は認めますけど
自分は惨めに思わない
自分がやってないんだからできないだけですよ
ああ 悲しいな なんて悲しいことですか
恥ずかしいな なんて恥ずかしいことですか
ピアノを弾けないぞとか
全然そんなことは思わない
時々子供たちいるんですよ
私には考えられないほどいろんな能力があるとかね
全然それでもこんなことばっかしやってるんだからできるんだよ
やってみればできるんだよと
だから心っていうのは柔軟性があって
やれば何でもできるものなんです
だから 時間の関係で 自分が生きている関係で
我々私は出家だから お寺の関係でできる仕事
できない仕事をはっきり分け分けちゃいます
分けるでしょうに それだけのことで区別があるんであってね
誰も惨めに自分を思う必要ないんです
やってみれば何でもできます
しかし やってみるといっても
この仕事別にチャレンジするっていうことはあまり良くないんです
本当は心の能力を 項目別に成功させた方がいいんです
例えば音楽とかなんとかというよりは
何に何をするにも集中力というものが必要なんですね
2番 一番最初に出てくるのは集中力なんです
なぜならば 心はシビアですよ
このシビアで仕事をするということは集中力なんです
それがないと心落ち着かないんです
機械が狂っちゃうんです
だからまず集中力というものを育てて
集中力ができたところで
では次に何するかと ピアノを弾くか
もう料理をプロになるかどうしたら後から決めればいいんです
いきなり料理のプロになるぞと思っても
落ち着きがなくて 話は理解できないわ
包丁はとってももうもうもう焦ってしまっているわというとできないでしょうに
ピアノのではドレミファで始まります
と言ったっても 集中力がないとできない
ですから 最初に集中力というものを育てた方が
もうそれで能力の基盤です
一切の能力はその上に成り立っているんです
どんな能力も 集中力は土台です
それで仕事を別に 能力別に機能別に育成する場合は
一番最初に出てくるのはこの集中力を育てること
2番目に出てくる仕事は
この不純物を取り除く
心から それ終わると終わりますよ
仕事 心が完璧になっているんです
この不純物を取り除く働きであらゆる能力は自動的についてきます
おまけにするおまけではないんですけど
あまりにも巨大なおまけで
ついてきます 例えば ただふざけて遊びに
もう宝くじでも買ってやろうかなと 1枚ぐらい買ったところで
それ 1 等賞当たった ただ遊びでね
いい加減にみんなでふざけていた時はね
もうもう買ってしまっただけですよという感じですけど
おまけはなかなか大変なもんなんです
おまけに当たったと ですから
この不純物を取り除くということで
すべての能力がおまけに当たってしまうんです
そこで なんで仏教は怒りやら貪りやら落ち込み
嫉妬やら あらゆる煩悩の話はすーっと喋っているかというと
この 3番目の仕事なんです
不純物を取り除けと これは不幸の元やと
能力は低下するもとやと
だから前の項目の 27 の項目の中にありましたから
欲が出てくるともう全く逆効果で
得たいものを得られなくなる
怒りが出てくると 相手に逃げられるだけじゃなくて
自分も破壊してしまうと
それで集中力を育てて
不純物を取り除く いわゆる欲を取り除く
怒りを取り除く そう簡単じゃないんですね
それで仏教はいろんな方法を教えるんです
欲を取り除く前にこれをしなさいという順番ちゃんとあります
科学的ですから いい加減にできるわけじゃない
私は怒らんぞと言ったっても
そうできるわけじゃないんです
それでなんで怒っているのかっていうことをちゃんと分析して
それを理解してアプローチを変えるということをするんです
なんで欲があるのかと
そこを分析してみて このアプローチをそこで変えるということをするんです
それでどんどんどんどん穏やかになるんですよ
例えば見えて体が重くなればなるほど生きづらいでしょ
重くて重くて心が 例えば高慢になればなるほど
ものすごい生きづらいでしょうね
生活しづらいんですよ
憎しみがあればあるほど楽じゃないんですね
だからすごく自由に この空気に流れている
もうなんとか綿のように
何て言うんですか あれは
たんぽぽみたいな感じで
すごく精神が軽くなるんです
で 軽くなるだけじゃなくて
自由自在にどこにでも何でもできるという
タンポポだったらどこかに落ちるだけなんですけど
心の場合はタンポポと違って自由自在になって何でもできるようになるんです
だからすごい仕事ですよ
不純物を取り除くっていうことは
決して怒り 欲なんかは可愛いと思ってはいけないんです
可愛くないんです 恐ろしいんです
自分の不幸を作っているんです
能力をどんどん硬くしているんです
だからこのゴムがすごく柔軟性があって伸び縮みするでしょ
これどんどんどんどん不純物入っちゃうと
時間経つと硬くなって硬くなって来なくなるんです
伸びるところが 曲げようと思ったらパチンと落ちるんだ
折れるんです だから古くなったゴムでも見てください
我々の心もそんなもんなんですよ
本当はいくらでも伸びるはずなんでしたけど
曲げても曲げても折れないはずでしたけど
今はちょっとしたことで心はもう折れてしまうんです
そういうことで 怒り 嫉妬
憎しみ 欲などなど 1500ありますからね
これをまとめてみれば三つですけど
貪瞋痴というね その不純物を取り除く作業にかかるんです
その作業なんですね 仏教でいうこのまずこの五蓋という話があります
なんで人の心は全然次元破らないんですか？見るもの聞くものだけで
遠く見たければ どうしても顕微鏡ではなくて望遠鏡必要でしょうし
小さいものを見たければどうしても顕微鏡必要でしょうし
結局目の能力は育てませんね
我々は身の回りの機械だらけで
機械に挟まれてどんどん機械ばっかり増える
人間はそのまま それは心の能力が育たないということなんです
お釈迦様の時代では 遠いところのものがすぐこちらに来て聞いていたんだから
お釈迦様はそういうふうによく人を育ててましたよ
遠い遠いところに 誰かが何かお釈迦様の聞いてる何か話し合っていると
いきなりサッとそちらに行くんです
行って 君たちは今喋ってたことはねとか
そこで話し合いなんです
で 聞いてるんですよ テレビ
ラジオがなくて だからお釈迦様の前に現代のアメリカの大統領みたいにあらゆる機械がね
あるわけじゃない 機械何もない
衣と鉢しか そういうことで
この我々の能力はなんでなぜこの我々にこの次元破れないかというと
誤解というものがあるんだよ
蓋が 5つあるんだよ で
それは取り除けと 一つは欲でしょ
2番目は怒りでしょ それからえーと怠けですね
昏沈睡眠 それからもう精神不安定な状態
で 後悔とかね 何でしたっけね
疑義ですね すぐに 頭があまり悪すぎて何でも疑う
で そこをちゃんとこの不純物だからね
そこを適当に取り除くようにしてください
それからこの五観というのは
この能力を育てるために必要なポジティブなエネルギーなんですね
1番目はサッダ サッダっていうのは信
信仰というかね いわゆる心はしっかりしている
確信がある 自信があるというような意味なんです
明るいというね 定義はそういう定義なんです
だからまあ大体みんな私に反対したりはしますけど
私は信といったらいろんな意味言うんですよ
あれは解釈学なんです
だからそれ覚えという今言いますけどね
我々のは解釈学というものがあるんです
それに沿っていろんな言葉を入れ替えるんです
そこで信 サッダっていうのは
たとえ日本語で漢文で信
信仰と書いてあっても
私はそれ確信 明るさ 自信があることとか
いろんな定義するんです
私はいつも理解っていうふうに思ってるんですけど
うん まあ理解というよりは納得なんです
正しく言えば 納得 なんで私は理解代わりに納得しますかって
この解釈学から見ると
サッダの機能は納得にあって理解にはないんです
納得したっていうのは気分がいいんです
落ち着くんです だから信の場合は
この気分がいいところ
落ち着くこと それが解釈のメインなんです
だからサッダということをするからです
それだから言葉を選ぶんです
理解すれば納得するし
気分が  そうそう それはそう
それ知ってますよ だから理解とは言わないんです
それは我々の違うところなんです
理解すれば納得なんですけど
理解しないと不安定で落ち着かなくなりますよね
それで問題は理解したんだからといって納得はしないんです
我々は理解するものは何でも納得するんだぞとはないんです
それは理解してないんじゃないですか
いえいえ 私はもうベストを尽くして勉強して理解はしていますよ
で みんなと話し合いもできます
納得はしない  論理的に正しければ理解はできるけども
納得はできない 前提とかが納得できないから
例えばタバコは体に悪いということは理解できるでしょ
でも納得は違うでしょ
そうですね  納得ができたら理解した重みがなくなるんですよ
理解するということは
なんかすごい荒っぽい作業で結構疲れるんですよ
納得したところで ほーっとして気持ちよくなるんですよ
そこで仏教はそれを先に出すんですよ
今の説明から見ると 先に出すべきじゃないでしょ
これ後から生まれる結果でしょ
でも仏教はあえてそれは 1番目にするんです
ポジティブの場合は なんででしょうか
これは即席進化心理学なんです
1番目に私はね 置いてあるから理解だと思ってるんですよ
違います  それ あの  1番目に置いてなければ納得で納得いくんですけど
最初に置いてあるってことは
やっぱり理解から始まるだろう
それは自分の考え方でそうなるんですけど
別にそんな間違ってるということではないんですけど
ブッダの思考パターンからブッダが発見している心理の法則から見ると
その順番違うではなくて
順番は信一ですよ  まさに心の癖を植え付けるっていう
いわゆる何をしても この機能がこの活性というか
円滑剤というかね この脂みたいなもんですよ
心が明るいっていうことが
なんで子供が大人より早く勉強するかというと
何も理解していないくせに結構明るいでしょ
だから子供に勉強させる
教育させる時は 内容より我々は先に遊ぶを出すんですよ
遊びを先に出すんです
いろんな遊びがあるんだから
いろんな色やら色違いやらいろんなものあるんだから
これで子供たちはすごくこれに惹かれちゃって
内容を勉強しちゃうんです
結局 子供の世界では先に喜んで
それから理解するんです
それが基本的なんです
子供の心は単純純粋だから
それを見ると順番がすぐわかるんです
だから まず明るく 軽い心で
穏やかな気持ちで始まりましょうと
あ 面白そうという感じで
で コーラン読むのやめたのはそういうことで
いろんなことがあって
面白そうと思って始めたら
これが違うと全然面白みが出てこなかったんですね
これがもう人間ではない方がいいと
他はこのもう想像できん
くだらんことでも勉強しますよ
もし皆様にバレたら なんであんたこんなことをやっているかね
別にも内容はあまりにもくだらんことは言う人より私は知ってますよ
でもどこかで面白いんですよ
バカげた話を言うとね
ニビ星が落ちるんだそうということも面白くて面白くて
でもあの そこで私は納得
さらなる納得ということではなくて
面白いんですよ そこで何を理解するかで
人というのはどれぐらいバカなもんを言ってるんでしょうかとかね
で 私の私の見方があるんだからね
やっぱり精神的な病気の人々が宗教を語るんだっていう私の大胆な
あの仮説ですか 仮説 仮説はありますけど
それはまあずっと証明しっぱなしで
反対の意見はなかなか出てこない
だからその仮説に当てはめてみる
でも気持ち悪いんだったら
それできんでしょうに
だから面白くて 全然嫌な気持ちも何もなく
そういう人々に対してもすごく親切な気持ちで言ってることは十分聞いてみる
それで自分の仮説のうちを整理はするし
嫌な気持ちで終わることでもないし
コーランではそのことはなかったんですね
聖書はいつでも読めます
納得してるわけないんですけど
面白いですね そこで面白さがもっと欲しいやと思ったら
さらに入り込んでやる
ですから この信というのは先に出しています
これは俗世間で言っている
何でもむやみに妄信することじゃないんです
それが反対 仏教反対ではなくて
それがネガティブなんです
いわゆる知恵に鍵をかけるんだから
だから妄信でない信って何なのかというと
一般人にはなかなか理解できない
これが何をやるにも楽しくやれということなんです
わかりやすく言うと   どうしてもやらなくちゃあかんだったら楽しくやりなさいよ
だからウェーサーカマッソラの準備の場合でも
私に言いたい 言いたいことはそれだけ
どうしても苦しい 大変といって
まあまあ 今日も明日もそうなるでしょうし
後々も大変でしょうしと思いますけど
そこはでもどうせやらなくちゃあかんし
他に人はいないし だったら楽しくやった方が何の損もなく得だけで終わっちゃうんです
あーやだ なんでそんなことやらなくちゃいかんかとかね
そう思わないのがいいんです
今はないんですけど 前だったら
もし私の場合は最終電車がなくなったら
よそそれでも歩いて行くんですよ
なんて不幸な人に安いやと思わないんです
だからそこはまあ信という機能の俗世間なバージョンで
ですから やることは何でもまず楽しくスタートだと
まず柔軟性があって 明るくスタートだと
信の次に出てくるのはサッダーの次にサティなんですね
サティっていうのは このどんな仕事でもこの分子単位で起こるんだから
時間の流れの中で あの
何と言いますか シリアル進行だから
あのデジタル放送と同じですからね
1本で来るんですよ だからサティでしかできないんですよ
このサティ使うのは間違ってパラレルにしないようになんです
パラレルになった瞬間でダメ
もう疲れる 嫌になる だからサティで気づきで
瞬間瞬間でやるんです
その能力 次に精進 頑張るというね
諦めないという この能力をするでなくちゃいけない
そう簡単には諦めないんだと
昨日もね もう全く文字は印刷してくれない
時間がなくなるわ イラ立ちはするわ
いろんなプリンターで試してみてもうまくいかない
で 私は諦めないで何をしたかというと
普通の絵を描くプログラムを開けて
そちらにその文字を入れて
そうすると絵になっちゃいますからね
絵はもう PS フォントじゃないんだから
絵は印刷してくれるので絵にしておいたんです
ではざまみろと そこで見事にそのもの上位させてくれる
そこでまた見ると やっぱりこれがちょっとかっこ悪いやと
いい加減なことだけど
それしかやることないんだから
これは最先最終というかいうかね
一番早くていい方法なんです
他にどうする思い浮かばないんですからね
みんなお手上げだし 私は負け負けません
とにかく何とかして工夫する
とりあえず腰を上げないというかね
何があっても そこはもう 4番目で
で  3番目ですね 次に順番で集中力なんです
この五根の場合はね 集中力と 5番目
智慧なんです 理解は本当は後なんですよ
最初の理解は理解にはならないんです
仏教でいう理解っていうのは
ものすごく このもう絶対変わらない
揺らがない 智慧智慧なんですね
だから理解っていうのは揺らぐんですよ
情報に基づいているんだから
揺らぐものは単なるヴィタッカと書いているんですね
概念の並び替え で それは五根も元になる質ですと
力になるものも同じことです
それから七覚支っていうものは皆様聞いていると思いますけどね
覚っていうのは悟ることの部品が 7つあります
それを 7つ揃ってくださいと
で また四念というものがあり
ヴィパッサナー瞑想の四念があって
八正道があって まあたくさんあります
37ありますね 悟るための必要な条件が
だからそういうふうに仏教の中で人は完璧にするために
このパラレルはとんでもない間違いだと
心がシリアルで動いているんだよと
それで最高の人間になるためには
こういうふうな順番で頑張ってくださいということになっているのです
じゃあそろそろこれで終わると思いますけど
システムダメだって古くないね
この文章は  はい お釈迦様は無数の能力の持ち主ですか
多数じゃないんですよ
無数の能力を持っていたんです
それも全部完璧に だから生命の中で
神々 梵天といかなる生命の中でも
お釈迦様に等しい能力の持ち主はいないんです
お釈迦様それは誰にでも頑張ればできるんだよということですよ
何の不思議もないんだと
別に個人ということじゃないんだから
法則だから しかし 何でもいっぺんになさることはしなかった
しかし 余計な妄想 エネルギーのエネルギーの浪費がなかったので
誰よりも早く行動することができたのです
そこら辺には我々のポイントがあるんですよ
お茶を入れながら手紙書くんじゃなくて
そうすると手紙の上にお茶がこぼしちゃってどうにもこうにも立派な結果になるんだけど
そうじゃなくて 手早く早くやればいいって集中して
エネルギーを浪費しないで
サティを持ってサティでさっさとお茶を淹れる
で サティで手紙を書く
そうすると普段分かかる手紙は分で終わります
つまり 20 分もわかってるんです
普段 30 分かかるお茶を淹れる入れ方が
まあそれも 10 分で終わります
また 20 分残ってるんです
だから 40 分トータルで残ってるんですよ
仕事 2つやって それが俗世間には同時にやっているように見えるんです
同時にやっているわけじゃないんです
無駄をしないだけ エネルギーは浪費しない
やることはぎゅっと集中してやる
雑念何もない 妄想何もない
ただそれだけですよ 秘密は
それで俗世間にはすごい早く見える
私もこういうものやら話やらね
まずまず考えなくちゃいかんでしょ
何をどんな内容 どういう風に喋ればいいか
2 3 秒はかからないんですよ
全部頭の中で作るためには
だからそのまま来て喋れますよ
物質にすると時間がかかるんですけど
遅くなっちゃいますけど
しかし  2 3 秒だから軽々しいわけじゃないんです
それには人を倒れるほどの集中力を使います
だから強烈な集中力で全部内容をサッと決めてしまう
その瞬間で 自分の記憶の中では全部
経典の全部やら 今まで勉強したものはあらゆることやら
世間の話やら全部入ります
だからこの別に早いというかいわなくて
エネルギーは使いますけど
やることは強烈な集中力で 1発で瞬発でやっちゃう方がやったらもう時間残ってるんです
残りの時間で別なことすればいいんです
まあそれからお釈迦様の言葉なんですけど
ドゥーランガマンエーカチャランアサリラングハーサヤン
イエーチッタンサンニャネッサンティモッカンティマーラバンドナ
これダンマパダの三十七
で ドゥーランガマンっていうのは
心っていうのはいろんなところで走り回る
だからもういい加減で
エーカチャランっていうのは一人で行くんだそう
何か打ち間違いいっぱいありますね
逃げ回る心はですよ もしがするとこの心かもしれません
書いた方の えーと 形が心
形が常に隠れていると書いたのは
心の実体がないんですよ
実体がないということは
ちょっと翻訳どうしても私には書けないんです
それは我々の解釈枠に反するんです
ですから このまあ こういうふうにしたんですけど
まあ形がって言ったって形もないんです
実体がない 心 実体がないんだったら存在しないと
そんな話じゃないんです
だからものすごいややこしいもので
全て支配しているものだからね
で ものすごく早く走り回っているんですね
このむさこいにいい加減に走り回ることが良くない
それはある方程式の中であるシステムの中で走らせれば役に立ちます
例えば ものすごく足が速い馬がいるんですが
その馬は野生の馬ですと
言うと役に立たないでしょう
つかみにくいでしょう
この馬ほど足が速い馬がないんだぞ
だったらその馬を捕まえて調教して競馬に出さなくちゃいけないんです
それでその馬が自分の足の速さがそのトラックで見せるでしょう
そこで優勝するんです
それで初めて馬の価値が現れるのです
野生の中で走る いくら走り回ったってその価値が出てこないんです
それを調教する人は魔から解放される
魔っていうのは苦悩から解放される
これは見事な歌に書いてますけど
どうします？ちょっと入れようと思ったんですけど
あの読み上げますか？ いじらでも
だからこれ作者に頼みましょう
持ってます？ 読みました
はい お願いします  心 心は形がなく
遠くまで飛び回り ある時は胸の奥に潜んでいるよ
心を捕まえ 静める人は
死の恐怖から逃げる 逃げるでしょうのが逃れるだろう
それはこの私はすごい新しい試みで
あまり誰もやったことない日本風な歌に入れ替えるというね
だからこの専門的な解釈的にはできませんだから
でもすごい立派な 今まで作っている歌はね
誰一人文句なく立派にできているんです
日本訳はいっぱいありますけど
ダンマパダの みんな同じことで文字変えて繰り返すだけでね
迷惑っていうかうるさいけど
やるんだったらそちらの方みたいにね
全く新しい 試みをしないと
まあそういうことで 次に
ワリジョーワタレキッとオオカノウコトウッバトパリパンダティダンチッタンマーラデイヤンパハテリ
敵に上げられた魚のように
この心は震えている 落ち着きがないという意味なんですね
やはり魔の領域 いわゆる不幸の境界を避けるべきだ
そこでこれで意味が通らないんですよ
もう一度パーリ語に戻ってください
我々の心がこの水から吸い上げられた魚のように震えている
怯えているんですよ だから我々はなんでも並行にやろうとして
欲であれもやりたい これもやりたいとかね
やってるんだからもう命取りになっているんですよ
心の能力はない 魚は本来持っている能力は何一つも現れないでしょ
魚にできることは もうほんのちょっとの時間が暴れ回ることだけなんです
それで不幸になってしまう
魚の場合は死んでしまう
我々はその道を選んでいるんです
だから魚だったら水に入れよとお釈迦様は言ってるんです
そうするとすごく自由自在にいろんな技を見せながら泳いでいるんです
魚の速さがもう人間には考えられないほど速いんです
しかし 魚は陸の上に上げて
こいつは歩けないんだぞとかけなしちゃってもね
話にならないんですよ
だから我々は場から離れてるんですね
心がそれ行ってるんです
我々は死の恐怖感のあるいてはいけない危険の境地の中にさらされているんですね
心が だからマーラでヤンマハというこの悪魔のマーラっていうのは死という意味はしますから
危険 恐怖 死 全てマーラ魔という言葉を意味してますから
その境地からは逃げるべきですよと
陸に上げられた魚だったら
早くも水の中に飛んだ方がいいんですよ
それで 34 番目 じゃあお願いします
じゃあそれの日本の歌
餌に食いつき 釣り上げられた魚のように
心は欲に食いつき 欲望の支配に引きずり回されているよう
大体歌の場合は 2回読み上げるという習慣が
餌に食いつき 釣り上げられた魚のように
心は欲に食いつき 欲望の支配に引きずり回されているよ
天皇陛下の歌会だったらね
なんか綺麗に唱えるグループいたんですけどね
今日はいないんですか？はい
次 ネパンマーターピタカエラアンジェーワースチャニャータカサンマーパニータンチッタンセイエソーナンカトゥーカレ
我々は正しく道を知って心を育てるならば
これは最愛の母にも父にも
また他の血縁者にも 決してしてあげることをできないことを優れたこと
正しく育てた心がしてくれるのです
だから我々に 我々に この心がどれほど幸福をもたらすこというと想像できないんですよ
こんなのは母にも父にもやってくれることできないんです
誰にもできない だから自分自身で心を育てなさいという意味で
自分で頑張りなさいと
これも同じ心の章ですから
あると思います じゃあよく聞いてください
母 母や父よりも兄弟よりも正しく育てた心は君に良いことをしてくれるでしょう
母や父よりも兄弟よりも正しく育てた君の心は
君に良いことをしてくれるでしょう
ありがとうございます
で それで一応終了です
まあ母父よりはまた言うことはないんですからね
なんかあるんですけど
出て出てきます 色はその色じゃないんですけど
ものすごい立派な色なんですけど
で これで終わりということや遊んでるんです
私が では あの もし質問とかね
しますか  あの心は神秘であるというところなんですが
具体的に考えてみますとですね
例えばその  私たちは人間で生き物ですけども
外から入ってくる情報というのは
物理的に見ればパラレルで入ってきているわけだと思ってね
同時 同時並行的に 例えば音を聞く場合ですね
音に限りますと 音っていうのは
空気の振動がですね 私の耳の鼓膜ですか
鼓膜を揺らしてるわけですが
無数の音波がですね あの鼓膜を揺らして同時並行的に入ってきてるんですね
だけども 私は今 長老の声も聞くし
質問者の声も それから外の車の音もですね
同時に聞いてはいるけれども
だからその鼓膜は同時並行的に鼓膜には引っ張られるんですね
音波が当たってるんだけども
聞き分けてるわけですね
それはどういうことかというと
今までのいろんなお話を聞くと
非常に速いスピードでですね
例えば長老の声に集中しててつなげて
同時にまたその外の車の音もつなげて
それらを合成して もちろんその視覚もあってですね
全体を見てるわけですね
それを同時にやってるわけだけども
よく分析してみると それ一人一人はシリアルにやって
それを合成していると
その合成されたそのプロセスみたいなものが進行してるわけですよね
それを心と言うんだという
その機能に心と呼んであって
だからおっしゃる通りに同時に聞いているんだという錯覚はあるんだけど
もう恐ろしい速さでこのシリアルプロセスしてるんですよ
あの 今のこのデジタル放送も同じことなんですよ
デジタル信号だから これはもう 1本で来るんですよ
しかし デジタルだからいくらでも早いんですよ
だからテレビ画面も映っちゃって
音も出して 文字放送も出てきてという
まあデジタルテレビだったらね
たくさんことやるでしょ
でもいっぺんにやってるわけじゃないんです
だからデジタルだからできるんですよ
だから心もデジタル的に働いているものなんです
全てデジタル世界だから
まあしょうがないんですけど
それとしての世界で考えると
それで恐ろしい速さで
車の音も私の声も 周りの人々の音も聞き取って聴覚を起こす
それから合成したりする
その時はなんとなくわかるんですよ
これ同時じゃないんだと
例えば 車の音に気がついた瞬間で
私の声は聞こえないんです
私の声に集中した時は
車の音全く聞こえないんですよ
あるにも関わらず そういうことに気づいてみると
同時じゃないんだぞとわかるんですよ
合成されたものを思い出すと
合成されたものとつながってるわけですね
合成されたものを我々は頭で繋がるんですけど
繋がり方も合成ですよ
しかし こちらで仏教はあえて言うのは
この合成したものが幻覚であって
心機能やとそれに我々は煩悩を作るんですよ
音に煩悩を作らないんです
合成したものに煩悩を作るんですね
例えば 私の話が気に入らなかったら
気に入らない 嫌だなという煩悩を作っちゃうんですよ
それは合成したからなんです
だから 怒り 憎しみ 嫉妬などはこの合成したから合成の結果なんですね
合成された  合成されたものに原点を置いてですね
また反射的にいろんなことを考えると
そうそうそう さらに煩悩が増える
その合成されたものの瞬間の原点ということが
私ということなんですね
テーラワーダでは私というのは
私と言いません 我々ですね
我々が合成された瞬間瞬間の原点を置いて
様々に見るというか それを
我というのは その我々はこの全ての合成をまとめて言ってる総合的なラベリングなんですよ
我はないんですよ 普通の世界で我々というのはこの合成した感情なんですね
だからたちが悪いんです
本当に我という言葉を使うのは
もうこの音を聞いて 感じて
考えて 感情を作って 幻覚まで作って
それ全部セットにワンセットに私と言っちゃうんです
それで言ったって そのワンセット
ワンセットが変化していくのに
その変化もまとめてまた私と言うんです
だから我というものは
我々は永遠不滅やと思ってるんで
それは単なる勘違いです
その勘違いに対して気づいていなさいというのは
仏道ですね それが悟りというんですね
他にご質問ございました？はいはい
論理学的に考えれば 一つのことを考えているから心とやって自分だと思うし
2つのことだったら私であって他で他人だっていう風に簡単に考えてわかるんですけども
どうしてそういう風な簡単な論理学的な体系によってでも
これは価値観の問題ですね
やっぱりこの証拠なく価値が先に出てるでしょ
私って存在 それは失敗です
価値っていうのは後からつけるもんですけど
人間の先に付けてるんです
それで価値を正当化させているんです
つけた価値が多い だから論理的にはわかるんですけど
そう言ったってもという気持ちになるんです
いつでも あんた言うことはわかるんだけどということで取得するでしょ
あれは価値論の誤りなんです
価値っていうのは感情ですね
結局は  ありがたいことですね
執着ですけど だから何の価値もいらんで
もうそんなもんかって感じで見るとくだらないこと言いますよ
だから例えば仏教はモガモガとか言ったっても
みんなそう言ったっても
やっぱりという気持ちで聞いてるんですよ
だからそれはどんな人間にもある問題で
先に価値をつける これにはすごい高い価値があるんだぞというふうに
まあそこからもう間違いだから
品物に価値を入れる場合は
品物を調べて価値をつけるのは後でしょ
論理的に言えば 箱を見たら
あ これは 1万円やと まずラベルを付けて
それから箱を調べると
くだらないガラクタしか見つからないんだけど
それでもそれでもととにかく 1万
1000万か 1万円で忘れちゃったんですけど
その値段に合わせをしているんですよ
だからずっといくらブッダが語っても永遠不滅の天国があるんだぞと
神がいるんだぞという考え方は生き延びちゃうんです
このヘリックスはいたり
観察して その恵み 観察した後に値段をつければいい
つけるっていうのは普通常識で考えて
普通誰でもやるはずなのに
その瞬間では間違ってしまうっていうのは
だからこれはもう未然というかね
これはもう虫が良からからやっていることだから
生命は 先に価値を入れて
それから調べると だからしょっちゅう現れます
神様の言葉に言ってる連中なんか
あの人で終わりませんよ
日本でもまたいろいろなわけで
忘れる時期を見て現れます
麻原が消えたところで
もういい加減やめればいいでしょ
いまだに何とかさんが科学の幸福の科学の人は元気にやっているでしょうね
で まあ彼が一応大学なんか行ったり勉強してるんだから
そこら辺でまあ誤魔化しできるんだから
まあ長生きできるところ
ポイントはありますけど
で またあのシロソースこととかね
もう平気で現れるでしょ
この前も京都で他でも私が仏だそうと言い張ったおばさんがいたでしょ
仏モジャモジャって何するんでしょうか
だからもうそんな現象もよく現れます
だから価値は後からつけてではなくて
もう価値がつけてるんだから
調べれば価値がないんだから
そうやって何て言いますか
気のままにインチキ的に
価値を入れると お経にすらっても言ってる内容なんかはもうただ誰にでも言えるくだらない話なんですけど
そうすると価値がないんですよ
で 強引に自分がブッダの生まれ変わりであって
創造は地球 宇宙創造する神様であると
で 強引に価値を入れる
そこで価値論の人々はもうもうずっともう信仰してひどい目に遭う
とかなきゃいけないな
頭がどんどん悪くなるんだからね
あんた全てそういった神様だったらね
まあ何でもいいんだから
ちょっとした花 1本ぐらいでもね
弁当一つだけでも創造してくれたらいいな
宇宙創造できできたバカに
だけど日本は大変きついでしょ
状態は  20トンぐらいの金の塊でも作ってくれれば
あるいは日本の天竜川でも何でも川でもね
まあ堰切してくれれば
まあ自然自然破壊になるかもしれない
それはもうこっちに一般人の技術でなんとかできます
いや 地下に石油をドーンと作ってもらえばそれでいいですけど
だからね でも人間 それはよく信じるということはどれほど無知かっていうことなんですよ
つまり 私の話は どんな失礼な乱暴な言い方という気持ちになるでしょ
先生 はい 何かを本当に理解できた時は
もうそれについて考えることはないんです
それで終わります 考える
それについてまた何か考えてるっていうのがわかってるわけじゃない
まだ不完全ということでね
納得いってないということなんです
あの その心の仕組みってではなくて
人間の生理学的なレベルでものを認識するときに
扁桃核っていうのが扁桃核っていうのと
それから大脳中枢というか
理性を司っているようなところっていうのが一応あるというふうに言われてて
扁桃核っていうのは 自分にとって危険か危険じゃないかっていう
非常にその あるいは好きか嫌いかって
それだけのことしか判断しないと
それはどうやって判断？も
過去のいくつかの記憶
一度見た記憶でもう長いものが蛇だっていうふうに
そういう記憶が入っていれば
長いものを見たら もうまず最初はそれは蛇だから怖いから逃げなきゃいけないっていうような
生理的なその人間の脳の仕組みがあるから
それを脱却しようと努力しない限り
やっぱし好きか嫌いか
自分にとって危険か危険じゃないかっていうのを表面的っていうか
しっかり理解できないっていう
そういう人間なり 他の生物の宿命的なものもあるみたいです
あるんですけど その場合でも
その脳が今生理的な説明をするところでも
もう一つ忘れてる基本があるんですよ
基準が価値っていうと守るという
その上でそういう機能ができているのです
だから我々のも最初に価値を入れるなよと
値札つけるのは後ですよということなんです
だから仏教の悟りは この脳の生理学では説明できない
心が最初にそれを作っちゃうっていうことですか
最初からもうすごい高価なものやとと決めつけてから
そういうなんとかせんとかなんとかとか
そういう気がするんです
だから自分にとって危険かないかとかね
それだけの単純簡単にできてるんでしょ
え なんで危険危険な価値がなければそんな判断する必要ないでしょ
とりあえずは自分の命を守るか
守れるか守れないかっていうのが出発点
生命にとって  命っていうのは守る必要もないでしょうに
命っていうのは変化していくものだから
守ろうと守らないが全然関係ないことなんですよ
別に終えないことで  命はとにかく自分を守るっていうか
自分を存在するっていうのが
そこはもうそれがまあ煩悩の煩悩って無知の始まりですけれども
それはもう全ての生命が出発点ですね
だからそれはだから輪廻の中の全ての生命の出発点を取れで
それはどこで破れるかというと
価値つけるところで破れますよ
簡単に値札は後につけましょうと
だからお釈迦様は無我ということをつけたのは
世界が我だよと言ってるでしょ
それでお釈迦様が我はなんなのかと値札を持って探したんです
どれかどれかに貼っておこうと
でも価値ない 無常なものには貼らない
それですべて終わったんで
調べて調べるのは一切調べたんだ
値札は手に取ってるだけで
それを落としちゃうんですね
イラク 落としたところは無我っていう言葉にしたんです
だからこのどんな微生物であろうが
誰であろうが この同じこの価値で生きているんです
それで危険か危険かないかとか
増えるか増えないかとかね
命は守られるかということでね
死なないようにするんだぞとかね
だから死っていうことさえわかってないんです
死ってなり立つか その言葉さえも
例えばものの合成であって
そのものの一部一部ずっと変化しっぱなしで流れっぱなしだったら
例えば川といえば水がずっと流れるんだから
川っていうのはなり立つんですかね
だから死っていうのは成り立つものかと
だからそこら辺わかって
この道元禅師はね 死を諦める
生を死を諦める人は生を諦めてもなんとかなんと書いてあるでしょ
正思惟なんとかっていう文章でね
立派な言葉ですけど まあ死をすることが生をすること
生をすることは仏法すること
だから小と小 私の日本語で言いますけど
小と死は別のものやと思う人は仏法ではありません
だから生は死であって
死は生であるんですが
小生同じ死と思ったらまた間違いになるという風に
なんかわけのわからないことを言ってますけど
本当はわけのわからないことじゃなくて
こういう  ある普通の人間と違う角度から物事を見ている
生きてるっていうことは死んでいるっていうことですよっていうことですね
そうそうそう だから生命はそんなことわからなくては死にたくないのを死にたくないと思っても
死ななきゃ生きていられないでしょうに
赤ちゃんが死ななきゃ次の生命になり立たないでしょ
私の細胞やらそれで死ななきゃご飯食べちゃうと
もう石がもう飲み込んだような感じで
それで死んでしまう だから食べたものは消えちゃうし
エネルギーは体に入るし
体が壊れるし だから次にまた食べるでしょうに
それが生きることでしょう
だから死がなしに生は成り立たない
だからずっと持ち運んでいるもので
ずっと生きている現象で
人間にとっては何か避けるべきものやと思うんです
避けられないんだから
だから仏教では瞬間死
死ぬべきなら瞬間死であると
瞬間瞬間の死 ただ体が痛くなることではないんだというふうにも言ってるんですね
そこの話は難しいになりますけど
まあ一応パチッと一言で処理できます
いいですか じゃあじゃあより高度なお話をだけは大丈夫です
ありがとうございます
今日はありがとうございます
お坊さんの三法に大戒律し
大乗のいいいいの瞑想とヴィパッサナーの調度によって生まれた
神 先祖 祖父母 よろしし親族
恩師をはじめとし 一切の生きとし生けるものに回向いたします
この功徳によって すべての生きとし生けるものが幸福に暮らせますように
そして 導かれられますように
サッビーティーヨーユアンジャントゥ サッバローゴーウィナッサトゥ マーテーバートゥアンテラーヨー スーキージーラーユコ
ーバワー バートサッバマングラッカントゥ サッバデーヴァター サッバブッダヌバーヴェーナ サッバダンマーヌバー
ヴェーナ サッバサンガーヌバーヴェーナ サダー スッティバワンプテ アビワーダナシーディッスニッチャン ワンダパ
ジャイノー ジャッターロー ダンマーワッダンティ アユワンノー スカンバラン
あっ  sorry で話するだけではどうも足りないですね